welcome to this video playing google oh
good pause oh and that's not right
pretty sure that's not right what does
this mean like a purse or something I'm
just guessing here okay I got a ready
here will he take the pawn and no one
going for fear and shadow can always
like this kind of position it's a little
bit better for white just a little bit
okay after night bt7 I feel happy to
play in the center so maybe just Knight
c3 am developing 92 was also possible of
course
okay give me the bishop pair I don't
mind that what to do majeur screen see
to him maybe for the C file and maybe I
should have taken before he has this
opportunity to take with the upon but ok
I can still play on the queenside here
without any big problem no let's just do
that
huh job I was just thinking that might
be might be as IDM Jack my bishop on b2
is not great she just going for g4 what
is he doing I mean therefore i'm just
taking eform that's not going to work ok
so i will have the farm for the moment
whoa really ok now he has to take one c3
hmm interesting not sure about all this
it might be just totally equal but I'm
not sure his king is a little bit
exposed and I have my is far more
realistic to believe that I'm taking
that that I am possibly taking his
seasick spawn then he taking one of my
pawns my pawn Cheney is very sound Queen
a 44 pressure on c6 my bishop has also
ideas to take the pawn later my pawn
chain is very what really you have time
for all this this luxury see that's
amazing maybe so maybe here for
threatening of Luke a seven ok
you
so Queen Queen over here to be 70 ed for
Queen B 7 will is just winning so you
cannot take on d4 I don't see how Queen
B 7 is pretty substantial
yeah if you push all your pawn sometimes
you came will be will be in trouble one
problem is that he cannot move his Queen
as the rook Hanks was check so not quite
sure what he what is movers maybe you be
eight or something but then I have Luke
c7 and I will win the pawn and if I win
c6 d5 is pretty much falling so Queen be
70 what is he doing after that we cannot
move the bishop yeah so I have queen d 7
now so one possible move but then look
28 somehow saving if i take here Queen
takes Queen c6 group chicks you can take
with the rook surprisingly okay okay six
I can't play okay six here maybe I
wonder if I'm missing something simple
it really looks a little bit like it 27
rook to e8 it's really holding
okay let's do that I feel like I'm
missing something but ok rookie six I
have roots c6 everything else fails i'm
not sure i'm winning there but it looks
like it winning two points but he might
get default back it could be a draw I'm
not sure if I'm making any sense here
okay just gives away the pawn down let
me take it
and then see what he's doing where's the
Queen going ok so i can take d for if
everything else else fails let's do that
first can't believe you can take with
the bishop maybe you can but doesn't
look like it ok now i can take g5 and
one day if that is actually the right
decision
not sure jam came really wasn't sure him
my my jacket ksh foyer and h4 hmm and I
overlooked that one it's fairly time
where there is saying that I overlooked
it he has those he has h4 yeah this is
irritating me quite a bit not right now
but the general idea is irritating me a
lot each form which which allows him to
go to F form okay let's just play this
this is a very meek move but at least
it's not getting this pick on a plane
check okay Bishop age 6 this is still
holding unbelievable that's unbelievable
okay maybe it's not a winning
check
now he cannot keep h6 protected Jeff
check check who was a bit tense black
forfeits on time Jim somehow I didn't
didn't find a complete complete kill
them they feel there should have been
one okay six computer grease ED forum
and now rook d6 okay what should I
actually do I took ok later when he
gives away a little bit of my advantage
but here yeah yeah I am he could have
done that the computer is a solid edge
form and now black is better that's
amazing him it's two pawns but black is
better because he gets the success to
the dark squares I have no move him
queen bee three is what the computer is
giving and then Queen f2 when black is
better amazing amazing I don't
understand that to be honest why is he
better after this Jack sticks windy form
we should be fine bone yeah yeah I saw
her aside but every didn't see what to
do against it okay Queen f7 was was good
yeah that's much better check this at
least keeps an advantage and now Jack no
I'm I'm flat out winning yeah it was
lucky he had this once this one-time
opportunity to play this to play this
age for move and he didn't he didn't
take this take this chance mom it was
lucky okay well thanks for watching